un retour au calme après près d'une
semaine de conflit meurtrier
à kamishli capitale de la région
autonome de facto du kurdistan syrien
des combats ont éclaté en début de
semaine dernière après l' attaque par
les troupes gouvernementales d'un poste
de contrôle tenu par les forces kurdes
conséquence plusieurs personnes ont été
tuées et d'autres blessées lors de ces
affrontements
dimanche dernier un cessez le feu
parrainé par la russie a été trouvé une
trêve permanente
arbitre et est garantie par les forces
gouvernementales et les forces russes a
été conclu dans la ville de qamichli les
forces de sécurité kurdes de la région
autonome du nord est de la syrie
resteront attachés à cet accord tant
qu'il ne sera pas violé par d'autres
partis ce lundi des véhicules russes
patrouillent et pour veiller au respect
du cessez le feu
les centaines de civils contraints de
quitter la ville pour échapper au
conflit ont pu regagner leur domicile
un soulagement pour ces syriens qui
avaient dû plier bagages dans la
précipitation
les affrontements ont commencé et nous
sommes partis aujourd'hui nous
retournons dans nos maisons nous étions
perdus sans maison nous n'avions même
pas d'eau dans la nature
maintenant nous sommes retournés dans
nos maisons pourrait résider à nouveau
si dieu le veut
cela fait une semaine et certaines
personnes n'avaient nulle part où
habitait les gens vivent et dorment et
dans les rues j'habitais dans une
mosquée pendant deux ou trois jours
grâce à dieu
les gens sont de retour chez eux
maintenant et nous voulions pas que
toutes ces choses arrivent nous ne
voulons pas de bombardements d' attaque
ni que tous ces civils show déplacés la
réalité est que nous exigeons la
sécurité et la dignité pour les
populations
nous voulons que les choses soient
stables avec de la discipline
la sécurité et la paix et c'est tout ce
n'est pas la première fois que des
tensions éclatent à qamichli entre
anciens alliés de la guerre contre edf
le gouvernement syrien ne reconnaissant
pas l'autonomie revendiquée par les
kurdes